اذا ورغم اتهامه بسبعه وثلاثين قضيه
جنائيه لا شيء سيوقف ترامب عن سباق
الرئاسه الى البيت الابيض هكذا اكد الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق بعدما قال انه بريء وهو
ضحيه مؤامره دبرها خصومه الديمقراطيون
لعرقله وصوله الى البيت الابيض الذي يامل
بالعوده اليه في عام 2024 وهنا يطرح
السؤال او يطرح السؤال نفسه هل يخوض ترامب
السباق من وراء القضبان وهل ستؤثر هذه
الاتهامات على اصوات ناخبيه هنا صحيفه
اعتبرت بانه كلما ازدادت الاتهامات
الموجهه الى ترامب سواء بدت ترامب اكثر
كضحيه مضطهده من قبل مؤسسه انتقاميه
يديرها ديمقراطيون راديكاليون وجمهوريون
بالاسم فقط ويميل هنا مؤيد الى تصديقه حيث
يعتقد ثمانيه من كل عشره بانه ضحيه وفقا
لوصف الصح طبعا هذه النقطه سيستغلها ترامب
جيدا وسيظهر نفسه كمستهدف وبانه يقاتل
ببساله ضد النخبه السياسيه الفاسده وهذا
بدا طبعا واضحا في مؤتمر الصحفي بالامس
عندما شدد ان لائحه الاتهام ضده مزيفه
ويحاكم فقط بسبب محاولته الفوز بولايه
رئاسيه ثانيه ترامب مشاهدينا اوضح في وقت
سابق انه سيجعل المحاكمه جزءا من حملته
الرئاسيه ونجح بذلك منذ لحظه توجيه
الاتهام اليه وتمكنت حملته من جمع اكثر من
اربعه ملايين دولار خلال 24 ساعه وايضا
وسع فيها الفارق مع اقرب منافسيه المتهمين
بالترشح على المهتمين بالترشح على بطاقه
الحزب الجمهوري لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات